despite you know all of the you know the
the plain inequalities that exist uh you
know which situation is better and I I
just think that the you know the
progress that has been made towards
those ideals is uh is undeniable
but you know that doesn't mean that you
then say well but everything's great and
you know let's not worry about existing
on injustices what you do as a liberal
as you say yes we're still not fully
living up to those ideals and so we need
to go ahead and correct them but our
society is correctable and we can you
know use policy uh and politics to make
changes to make things better
foreign
[Music]
it is my privilege to welcome to forward
political science PhD from Harvard
University senior fellow at Stanford now
the author of 10 books including his
latest liberalism and its discontents
Frank fukuyama Francis fukuyama
technically welcome Frank how are you uh
very good Andrew thanks very much for
having me on uh it's a pleasure I quoted
you in my last book uh I've been in
admirer of yours intellectually for a
long time but in my last book I quoted
you as saying America is in danger of
becoming what you called a vetocracy
which is that I can't do anything but I
can keep you from doing anything
right yeah so political scientists talk
about political systems and how they
differ from one another from country to
country in terms of how many veto points
there are that is to say these blocking
uh uh Provisions in Constitution and in
law that allow people to stop things but
not necessarily to do positive things
and the United States has a lot more
than other democracies and I think we've
seen our system kind of freeze up over
the last few years because of them yeah
we have more choke points as you pointed
out in some of your earlier books and I
get the sense that the focus of your
thinking has shifted over time there was
a period when
liberalism Classical liberalism seemed
ascendant in the world
um X number of years ago and then it has
essentially been in Decline uh for the
last number of years Wendy is that fair
to say and when do you think that that
decline started uh yeah I think that it
really picked up steam in the middle of
the second decade of the 21st century
and it was attacked right from both the
right and the left the the one from the
right is one we're pretty familiar with
you have all these populist nationalists
politicians all over the world from
Victor Orban and Hungary to Donald Trump
in this country who basically are not
liberal and by liberal I don't mean
liberal in the American sense of
progressive or left of center I meet it
in a classical sense where individual
rights uh equal individual rights are
protected by a rule of law and by
constitutional checks and balances and
the common characteristics stick of
these populists is that they admire
strong men that aren't constrained by
these kinds of checks and balances and
that's why I think a lot of them
actually admire Vladimir Putin because
he's a kind of archetype of a strong man
who doesn't have to listen to anybody
before he makes a decision invades a
neighboring country you know so forth
and that critique you know of liberalism
says you know liberal societies are weak
they're indecisive they don't set Higher
Goals for themselves and so forth but I
also think that there is
a problem on the left because one of the
core values of a liberal Society is
tolerance and freedom of speech and
those principles have been under attack
by a lot of progressives who uh you know
they they
claim that they want to protect
diversity but it's a only a certain kind
of diversity having to do with race
ethnicity gender Sexual Orientation
Diversity and political opinions
diversity and attitudes towards religion
or certain kinds of values they don't
they don't want to protect so much and I
think there you've seen also an attack
on liberal values and institutions and
so I think both the left and the right
have kind of converged in saying that
liberalism is passe you know that was
the baby boom generation believed in
that but you know we want something
different
yeah and and those are the key ideas in
your book liberalism and it's
discontents you define Classical
liberalism uh as rule of law and free
media and checks and balances and a lot
of these institutions of democracy that
America has uh benefited from over the
last number of generations and now
those institutions are very much being
threatened and you characterize the
threats as coming from both sides but in
different ways and I I thought that your
book was in some ways an incredible
summation of what a lot of people are
thinking about but didn't put it in a
sophisticated language uh as as you have
so let's retrace that argument a little
bit uh so where did the classical
liberal tradition uh come from
originally
well it's very old it really originated
in the middle of the 17th century after
Europe's Wars of religion you know
following the Protestant Reformation
Protestants and Catholics spent the next
150 years killing each other all over
Europe over you know questions like
transubstantiation is the you know is
the Bread and Wine the actual Body of
Christ or a representation of uh his
blood and body uh and you know at the
end of that period a lot of liberal
thinkers said maybe we shouldn't be
killing each other over these uh visions
of the good life maybe we should just
protect life itself and so the right to
life that is in the Declaration of
Independence you know really comes from
that belief that it's basically just
life itself that needs to be protected
in a regime that tolerates a variety of
visions of of the good life in the 19th
and 20th centuries instead of religion
it became nationalism you know these
very aggressive uh assertions of
national identity that said that one
group is superior to another group and
could conquer other peoples and repress
ethnic groups within their own society
and again in 1945 you know people said
well maybe that's not such a great way
to organize at least Europe maybe we
should have a liberal order in which
tolerance and rule of law protects the
rights of everybody regardless of what
group they're a member of and so
you know it it went wrong
at several points in history and we come
back to liberalism in the end because it
is a way of managing diverse societies
and so you have these classical liberal
Traditions that arise in Europe and that
America very much codifies uh in its
founding documents or at least tries to
I mean you know like you characterize
that look but like our thinking has
evolved certainly since since the
Declaration of Independence and the the
Constitution
um but the fundamentals the foundations
have been in place really over that time
and now there is a a breakdown in the
confidence and faith in these
institutions on both sides but that the
attacks or misgivings are somewhat
different on each side
um so on the right side you have uh this
trumpist populism is one version but you
also have conservatives who feel like
their values are being threatened by
what they see as activist institutions
yeah it's uh it's a mixture of things I
think that many conservatives uh really
want a society in which there's more
consensus over basic religious values
and so you know the national
conservatives now these are the
intellectuals that are trying to put
this into a more theoretical framework
say that every society needs a dominant
religious set of beliefs and you know in
a way liberalism arose because nobody
could agree what that dominant set of
values were and uh you know it's really
kind of rolling the clock back several
centuries to say that we are going to
have uh you know this one set of goals
which we're headed it but you know
that's one of the problems with the
liberal Society because it doesn't set
these Higher Goals people feel that
there's kind of a lack in their life of
a sense of community a strong sense of
community that will bind them to their
fellow citizens and I think that's one
of the things that's that's driving this
I think in the American context and in
other European countries there's
something else which is that
there's a feeling that they personally
are being devalued they're not being
respected if you're kind of working
class white guy that's lost his job
over the last few years or is working
you know flipping hamburgers instead of
working in a steel plant or an auto
Factory uh you know that person feels
like the society doesn't value his labor
the way it valued that of his father or
his grandfather and it's very easy in
those circumstances to blame other
people for that situation particularly
because in America right now there are a
lot of people are doing really well you
know you go to Wall Street or you go to
Stanford University where I am or
Silicon Valley and there's you know a
lot of billionaires that have made a
tremendous amount of money and so I
think a lot of the resentment has to do
with that inequality that has emerged
that give a lot of advantages to a
certain class of people and their
children but really aren't extended to
you know the whole of the society
guess what just came out on paperback
it's forward out on October 4th you can
buy it in any bookstore near you and if
you use the promo code Yang you get
absolutely nothing this is your chance
if you were waiting for a cheaper
version of the book it's on October 4th
pre-order it I really am proud of this
book uh it's something that you have to
read to believe all right forward out on
paperback thank you everyone
[Music]
foreign
so you have critiques and problems
coming from from the conservative side
where there's a group let's call them a
white working class men who feel like
they're increasingly on the outside
looking in uh for a host of reasons and
then there are critiques from the left
uh that you catalog very interestingly
and one of the elements and this is
where it gets interesting uh well I mean
it's all interesting but where
liberalism is trying to have people in a
diverse Society say look we're not going
to agree on everything but let's agree
that these institutions are here to
mediate what happens to us and I can
believe one thing you can believe
another but I can't impose my beliefs on
you uh like that that's for our
institutions to sort out and we should
just agree that we'll we'll submit
ourselves to the rule of law and and uh
and uh
uh the Judiciary and like what whatever
else the the uh the setup is and then uh
on the the left now increasingly there
is this dissatisfaction
um that's born of a new version of uh
identity politics that has been the
successor to the Civil Rights air
identity politics which you present as
trying to live up to the promise of
liberalism where liberalism says look we
all have life liberty in the pursuit of
happiness and there are certain groups
that are have been excluded from that
for historical reasons let's say
um let's say African-Americans uh during
the Civil Rights era movement saying
we're on the outside looking in so let's
try and fix that
um but then that critique has now
morphed into something else
um uh in part because of a series of uh
academics who've made uh post-modernists
uh arguments that have been and
coalesced into a contemporary version of
identity politics that at least is
prevalent in certain contexts yeah no
that's uh that's right I think that
there's a liberal form of identity
politics that says that people are
should be treated as individuals and
judged as individuals but the society
looks at the color of their skin or
their gender and treats them differently
and therefore the liberal society never
lives up to its promise of equal
treatment and therefore uh you know what
we want to do is just make that liberal
Society really
live up to its own ideals and that I
think is is fine I I don't see any
complaint you know that you can make
about that as a as a liberal because the
fact of the matter is you know as you
alluded to in 1789 when the Constitution
is ratified the only people who could
vote were white men with property and so
this equal you know the the human
equality and the Declaration wasn't uh
uh wasn't remotely the reality in the
United States uh and so that's a liberal
version of identity politics where
identity is simply a tool for
mobilization but I think what's happened
in a lot of contemporary uh societies
particularly in the US is that people
move on to say well actually the that
fixed characteristic like your race or
your gender is so important uh and it's
so essential that that's the most
important thing that defines you as a
human being and not who you are as an
individual and the society needs to
treat you based on that group that
you're a member of they're not as an
individual and I think that's where it
starts to undermine liberal principles
because you know liberalism asserts the
universal Dignity of all human beings
not dependent on what group they're a
member of but you know simply because
they're human beings and you know as a
practical matter that means that a lot
of progressives
you know will argue that just being
white uh
you know means that you're in a position
of permanent uh privilege and because
you can't really remediate that uh you
know you have to kind of reverse the
hierarchy and and privilege other people
and I think that's not the best way to
organize a society yeah that's something
that I think people are struggling with
right now where you have a very
legitimate so I I went to Brown
University and
um I was steeped in the Civil Rights era
language uh that that was then applied
to other communities of color certainly
there there's this idea of a civil
rights movement that grows to Encompass
uh sexual orientation uh Asians and
Latinos pretty much anyone who's in a
marginalized group and because our
Paradigm is very much around the Civil
Rights era everyone says oh like we
should have a movement to try and uh
achieve equality for for each of these
groups
um so that's the way I was trained
academically if you will uh and uh there
there's been an evolution since then
um where now instead of arguing for a
particular policy
um you are now uh saying that
all of the institutions are so
irredeemably uh racist uh or sexist that
it's difficult to find
um like a policy that's being advocated
for individually
um which would be in your sense like a
lib like a liberal thing to do is to say
hey look like I can uh you know like the
institutions are not working so let's
argue down institutionally
um but now there's this this other
intellectual movement that's actually
undermining liberal institutions uh by
saying that the group is more important
than the individual I'm defined by the
group I belong to and these institutions
are unable to uh actually
uh reform themselves meaningfully yeah
that's no that's right I mean basically
the argument that well so critical
theory is become a meaningless word
because conservatives have picked it up
as this big boogie man but it does have
a serious uh intellectual history uh as
a critique of liberalism and you know uh
many of the uh more serious versions of
critical theory said uh basically that
you know your Society claims to be
liberal but it's actually kind of a
facade and that underneath that
profession of equal treatment is
actually the dominance of some groups by
other groups and that that's the reality
it's really those um those hidden Elites
that are stacking the deck using the
language of equality of liberal equality
to fool everybody into thinking that
they live in a just Society but they're
actually not that it's a deeply unjust
one and you can't use liberal techniques
to you know to to correct a structure
that is stacked against you know these
marginalized people and that's the
um that's the assertion that I've I find
very questionable because it does seem
to me that in the history of liberal
America for example we actually have
made a lot of progress I mean uh you
know there's a certain line that says
well there's a continuity between
slavery and lynching and Jim Crow and
police violence but honestly you know if
you you asked an African-American person
you know would you rather be a child
slave in South Carolina you know in 1830
or
um you know living today despite you
know all of the you know the the plain
inequalities that exist uh you know
which situation is better and I I just
think that the you know the progress
that has been made towards those ideals
is uh is undeniable
but you know that doesn't mean that you
then say well but everything's great and
you know let's not worry about existing
on injustices what you do as a liberal
as you say yes we're still not fully
living up to those ideals and so we need
to go ahead and correct them but our
society is correctable and we can you
know use policy uh and politics to make
changes to make things better
foreign
from our sponsor betterhelp here at Ford
we're all about solving problems find
the solution but the fact is sometimes
our brains aren't really in a position
to be productive and find the light at
the end of the tunnel sometimes things
seem hopeless sometimes you just get
really down your friends and family or
the things you enjoy don't bring you the
same enjoyment and when you're in that
state you really could use some
professional help I saw a therapist for
the first time when I was a teenager and
I've been a huge believer ever since my
brother Works in mental health if you're
thinking of giving therapy a try better
help is a great way to do it it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online you can get matched with
a therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch anytime when you want
your brain to solve problems therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com Yang
today to get 10 percent off your first
month that's better
help.com slash yang
[Music]
yeah and and one of the underpinnings of
Classical liberalism and you talk about
how it is aligned with the scientific
method uh where you kind of assume a set
of shared facts and one of the major
struggles we have is that at this point
it's tough for both sides to uh to agree
on facts and certainly we can see that
on the the right where there is and you
characterize it in the book
interestingly you say look let you know
there are people who genuinely believe
the election's stolen you know like like
that like they but for them that that's
just the what what they think happened
uh but but that we have different
version of facts that are arising
um and uh and that's something that
unfortunately is starting to come up
from both sides yeah so there's a
complex uh background to all of this you
know part of it
um has to do with us again with critical
theory actually uh you know there's a
view that appeared on the left uh in
post-modernist thought that was probably
best articulated by Michelle Foucault
that said that science claims to be this
objective approach to cognition that
simply reflects objective reality but in
fact it's something that's used by
Elites to manipulate people and he said
this whether with respect to
homosexuality
incarceration Madness you know all of
these were categories that were
basically used by hidden Elites to keep
people down and you know honestly in the
cases that he cited he did a lot of
historical studies of the way that
prisoners were incarcerated and the
reasons for which they were incarcerated
and there's a lot to what he was saying
you know this is a way to hold down
lower class people and keep them from
making demands on the system but he then
generalized this to say that in general
science is really not objective it's
it's simply a tool that's used by
powerful people to manipulate
others and you can see now that that
argument that begins on the left has now
drifted over to the right so you think
about the
coronavirus epidemic and you know the
refusal to believe that public health
authorities that we're telling people to
get vaccinated or to wear masks people
simply did not believe that that was
based on science that this was simply an
effort by you know powerful people to
manipulate and use that power uh you
know to force uh others to to bend to
their will and so now it's something
that's shared you know on both sides of
the spectrum but I would say another
really critical thing that happened in
the interim is technology yeah
you know so I uh indicating how old I am
you know when I was a kid in the 1960s
there were three television channels
broadcast TV channels and you had to get
all of your news pretty much from one of
those three and they were pretty much
indistinguishable but it also meant that
there wasn't
um this possibility of having these
radically different uh views of reality
uh whereas you know with the rise of the
internet anyone can say anything right
there's no uh necessary fact checking
there's no higher hierarchy of credible
sources uh and therefore if you you know
type in uh to Google you know uh our
mRNA vaccine safe you'll get you know
thousands of hits that will say oh no
they're completely unsafe this is really
something terrible that's being done to
you and um you know frankly
that's destroyed the possibility of
having a common empirical base of
knowledge I mean we agree in a liberal
society that we're not going to agree on
the highest things as defined by
religion but you know if you don't agree
who won the last election or should I
you know take a vaccine then you're
going to end up in a lot of trouble uh
and I think that's exactly where we are
so some of it is due to this skepticism
and distrust of of science but it's also
due to I think a technology that kind of
flattens everything and and sort of
makes everything equal every fact is as
good as every other fact even if some of
those facts are completely untrue well
you'll be happy to know Frank I also
remember when it was just three networks
uh ABC CBS and NBC and then Fox was born
and The Simpsons came on our TVs and it
was the 80s so I remember uh and and
totally agree that social media and the
proliferation of uh sources of
information has now led to a splintering
of the American Consciousness and it's
tough to bring everyone back if you
can't agree on facts
um and that's one of the foundations of
liberalism is that we have to be able to
stare at and have facts that we can
agree on so you make a series of
recommendations
um first you go through liberalism and
and then you say hey for all these
critiques is there a better way and you
argue well not really I mean we pretty
much have to try and to stick to this
yeah so so let's figure out what the
path looks like
um so one argument you make is that you
don't want to base national identity
around for example membership in one
ethnic group or another if you can help
it that if you could invest in national
identity in intelligent ways like that
that's worthwhile I'm going to tell you
a story about something uh so it was
during covid and I wanted to do
something positive around and Asian
Americans and you know like not not
beating us up
um and so I helped start a campaign
called all-americans say pretty much
saying we're all Americans you know like
we're all in this together
um and there were people who actually uh
found it problematic that I I was uh
both using American and the flag
um to denote diverse communities or
Asians in particular because they
actually thought that the phrase
All-American meant let's say Caucasian
uh blonde people or something along
those lines
and I was like well the point is that I
consider myself uh American and
All-American and you know so should you
and you know it's like if we give up on
um that identity and the flag and you
wrote a book called identity so you know
like you went in pretty deep on this I
so I always felt like uh American
encompasses uh all of us
um and if we can invest in that
meaningfully uh that's a win
um but I I will say that I was kind of
surprised and I also felt like it was
something generational where I'm in my
40s and so for me like it's like yeah
sure we're all American and that but
there were people who were younger
um who actually like chafed at the
notion of using uh that term
All-American or American or the flag
like uh on diverse communities yeah well
so there's a couple of different sources
of that when I was young
uh you know I grew up in New York City
and uh there wasn't a large
Japanese-American or indeed not that big
an Asian you know sub-community uh in in
the city and you know as I was growing
and then we moved to central
Pennsylvania because my dad taught at
Penn State and that was an even more
about a ton of Asians in Central PA huh
Frank
you know and so I would get teased you
know by white kids and made fun of and
so forth and so I thought you know and
I'd ask my father well you know when
people say where are you from uh what do
I say and he said just say I'm an
American and they say well but where
where did you come from you say I was
born in Chicago uh you know that's all
you need to say because an American
doesn't denote a person of a certain
race uh it simply denotes somebody that
has taken you know that is a citizen
that take is loyal to the ideals of
America and you qualify and I always
thought that that was a tremendous
achievement that I was living in a
country where you know coming from a an
Asian family I could associate myself
with the dominant you know cultural
group in the society and not feel uh
embarrassed about that and I think if
you go to a naturalization ceremony uh
you know anywhere in the country it's an
unbelievably moving experience because
you get all these people from Korea from
Iran from Guatemala you know all over
the world that take the oath of
naturalization and then at the end of it
they're declared Americans and I just
think that's such a big achievement and
they're very few countries where you can
actually do that you can't do that you
know in Germany or Sweden or a lot of
European Democracies where you know the
the the very adjective uh uh German or
Swede or Japanese for that matter
doesn't denote simply a citizen of that
country it denotes a member of the
dominant ethnic group right so I think
that that was a tremendous achievement
of the United States but now you're
getting these people on the left that
say you know I don't want to be an
American I don't want to associate
myself with that dominant group I proud
to be the member of this you know small
subgroup and and that's really who I
care about because these are people like
me and I think that that basically takes
them full circle to join hands with all
the nationalists and racists that say
that you know these um these kinds of
characteristics are what are important
and not your loyalty to a set of uh
liberal and democratic ideals that for
me uh defined what it meant to be an
American and I think you know were being
dragged backwards both by these
Neanderthal people on the right that
still think of an American as being a
you know white person but also by people
on the left that kind of accept that and
say yeah we're different and we're proud
of it and we're not gonna you know we
don't want to associate with you
to protect your online privacy you
should use a virtual private network
expressvpn is the one that we recommend
I trust expressvpn because it gives me
peace of mind that when I browse online
no one is tracking my data no one can
later figure out what the heck I did
it's fast it's easy to use it's just one
button it's literally so user friendly
that anybody can use it and it's the
highest rated VPN used by Fortune 500
companies rated number one by Business
Insider Verge and many others don't take
my word for it sign up today protect
yourself with a VPN that so many people
use and Trust for their online privacy
use my link expressvpn.com Yang today
and get an extra three months free on a
one-year package that's
expressvpn.com Yang visit expressvpn.com
Yang to learn more
um so so this is one of the things I
wanted to discuss with you there are a
couple big things I mean you've very
effectively cataloged some of the
dysfunctions of our institutions uh and
what what I in in terms of the vitocracy
what we opened up with
um and so I think that there's a lot of
frustration and energy Rising on both
sides what I'm doing now is hoping to
modernize and Advance some of our
institutions so they're more genuinely
responsive and representative and don't
have this
effective uh disenfranchisement and
disempowerment of the vast majority of
Americans which I by the way totally
believe is a huge part of this problem
so you you make you make a series of
recommendations
um I I feel like uh like there are a
couple of big directions we should be
taking one is to try and upgrade and
modernize various institutions so that
they are more responsive and and uh uh
accountable and proactive because right
now there's so many of us who just look
up and say like you know like do I
believe in these institutions and and as
you say uh the mistrust is rising like
the trust is uh declining fast
um and so that the the response right
now in my opinion is not a genuine
upgrading of most of these institutions
is trying to talk about them better it's
like the institutions then it's like oh
we just need to invest in better social
media accounts and then people will
trust us more and like I don't think
that's the answer so like we have to try
it and upgrade them
um but you also make a series of
recommendations around and I'll talk
about one that's hugely important where
you compare the conservatives in America
to the conservatives in the UK and the
conservatives in the UK decided to
expand the franchise and say look our
ideas uh will win with people of
different backgrounds and by the way I
think this would work in the US and in
many ways because you can see for
example more Latinos uh heading to the
Republican party and like more people I
will say too there are there are some
Fed Up Asians that are heading that
direction too and so
um and so you could compete and expand
the franchise the dark path the path
they're taking is to try and curb voter
participation and make it harder and say
hey even though we're a declining number
we're going to to maintain control by
trying to just make it tougher uh and
and you argue very convincingly that
look like there actually is a better
path that's better uh for democracy
itself and liberal institutions I might
actually work better for that group now
I'm not optimistic that they'll take
your advice but I thought it was a very
compelling argument
no I mean I think the Maga Republicans
are painting themselves into a corner uh
where they're saying you know we're not
going to create this big tent we're not
inviting a lot of people in
uh but because they are not a majority
of the country it means that they're
going to keep losing elections unless
they start manipulating those elections
or you know pushing for non-uh
Democratic outcomes and that's you know
not a good formula it's a formula for a
lot of civil strife and ultimately I
think it's going to hurt it's going to
hurt them uh you know the 19th century
British
British conservative approach really was
the one that was taken by Benjamin
Disraeli who you know pushed the second
Reform Bill that opened up the franchise
to a lot of working class British people
and it turned out that they could be uh
they could be motivated by patriotism by
certain pride in their you know their
National institutions and uh you know
that was the basis for their dominance
of British politics really up until the
early 20th century and I think the
Republican you know the Republicans had
been on that path under Reagan you know
Reagan did not have an ethnic
understanding of who is an American he
was uh you know happy uh content with
immigration uh you know accepting other
people that wanted to join the American
Family he was open to the world and
internationalists and so forth and that
it seems to me is a very you know
powerful formula but right now that's
not that's not worth much of the
Republican party is unfortunately yeah
so uh I I'm pessimistic that they're
going to take your advice but I thought
it was a very very useful historical
example
um you also discuss allowing communities
to make more decisions for themselves
and not nationalizing and federal and uh
and making everything the decision of
the federal government which I thought
was very very interesting I mean that's
also uh very aligned with a lot of what
we're doing with forward is we're trying
to go to communities and give people uh
more choice in local races because now a
majority maybe up to 70 percent of races
are uncontested or uncompetitive and so
people don't have any meaningful Choice
um I was just in Missouri in a district
that's uh this great great woman
I was looking at running I'd say her
name but you know I don't want to put
pressure on her decision to run
um but she was running in a district at
60 40 Republican uh and if you were a
Democrat it's a waste of time because
you're going to lose
um and so she's hoping to run as forward
party in that district and she's a civil
engineer uh she's kind of a rational uh
middle of the road type and her argument
is look like I want to run as forward
party because I think I could get all
the Dems as long as they didn't run
anyone themselves and then I think I
could get 20 of the Republicans because
a lot of them are like me and so that
that's her plan and that's something
that hopefully we can help her with in
Missouri
um but that that's our hope in a lot of
districts uh around the country so that
you could actually get people uh in
position where they could make a
difference in their town and their their
school district uh in their County like
whatever the unit of government is
um so that that's a lot of what the
forward party is driving towards there
are people that would be be very upset
about that approach in terms of saying
look we should stop federalizing every
issue but I I think that what you were
saying is uh really important that maybe
we should let communities decide more of
these things yeah I think that in
American constitutional history there's
certain issues that should be
um
decentralized in decision making and and
given to you know local communities but
there's others that you can't you know
do that with and so the prime example of
the latter had to do with slavery right
yeah before the Civil War people in the
South said well that should be up to
local communities to and if we want that
institution we should be allowed to
decide democratically to have it and it
was Abraham Lincoln that said in his
debate with Stephen Douglas no that's
not true not everything can be decided
by a local Democratic majority there are
some things that are a matter of
principle like the equality of all human
beings it's enshrined in our Declaration
of Independence and therefore that has
to be taken out of the realm of
democratic choice because that's a
fundamental uh value but you know a
question of do we spend our money on on
a road or do we buy a sports Stadium or
do we you know do something else with
the local tax dollars though there's
really no reason why that shouldn't be
made by the local uh community and so
you know if you exempt a certain
category of fundamental rights you know
based issues that I think absolutely you
should give communities uh the
opportunity to to make their own
decisions and you know with regard to
something like Health Care maybe you do
need certain National minimal standards
for if you're going to have a National
Health Care System
but you know there's probably some
virtue to having States implement it uh
you know as they see fit it may mean
that not everybody gets treated
uniformly but I I think that you know as
long as you are providing the basic you
know Health Care the actual detailed way
in which it's done you know could
probably be left up to localities
[Music]
so if you buy and I think you do that
this argument that look these
institutions we need to try and uh
resuscitate them because this is the
best system we have the best hope we
have
um what what are reforms uh that you're
excited about to the extent that you
think that there does need to be some
kind of Rejuvenation uh of of some of
these mechanisms because they are
overrun by corporate influence as you've
pointed out uh that there are a lot of
Choke points it's very hard for a lot of
Americans to recover faith and
confidence that these institutions are
going to suddenly get up and throw off
all of like the the the the the Fetters
uh and there are different people that
are mad for different reasons like some
might be like hey why can't we address
climate change others might might you
know I might be angry about right um
something we do do there's as you can
and as you know in your book there's
such rampant mistrust that at this point
everyone's mad about potential overreach
um so you you have these overlapping
concerns where everyone's upset
one of my favorite quotes of your book
is you said look it's not about the size
of this state it's about its quality
like the quality is much more important
what can we do that would make the state
actually better like what are what are
your top uh hopes for what we do
yeah there's several different uh
answers to that question
um
you know the first has to do with
institutional changes that will reduce
polarization
uh so with with respect to your uh
prospects for the forward party you know
the most important of them is changing
the voting system amen because let's go
unless you unless you move to ranked
Choice voting or better yet proportional
representation then you know I think
third parties really have a really hard
time getting any traction uh so that's
one thing I think you could uh limit the
terms of Supreme Court Justices so this
sure uh you know you don't have these
huge Stakes of appointing somebody
that's going to be on the bench for the
next 40 years you could limit it to 18
or even you know a shorter length of
time you could get rid of the filibuster
I'm not sure I'd take it all the way
down to 50 in the Senate but you know if
you simply reduced it to 55 it would be
a little bit counter-majoritarian
um but you know it wouldn't block things
uh as much as they're blocked under the
current system if you only need it you
know a small handful of senators from
the other party to to agree so those are
some some things that could be done now
in terms of actually
making the government more effective I
think that
we really need to reform the the Civil
Service particularly the federal civil
service uh you know I know that a lot of
Republicans think that that's the Deep
State and they're actually out to
destroy the Civil Service
uh you know uh the Trump Administration
right before the election issued this
executive orders on creating a schedule
F that basically would eliminate all
protections for federal civil servants
and allow them to fire uh whoever they
wanted and I think that you know we
actually need to move in the other
direction to improve the professionalism
uh and the non-partisan impersonal
character of our civil service uh right
now you know for just to give you one
small example something like only four
percent of federal bureaucrats are under
the age of 30. and if you're talking
about a government that's Savvy about
technology
and you know understands and is
comfortable with using technology I
think you're going to need a few more 20
year olds yeah I'd say so mix in fact I
mean the average age of federal
bureaucrats is it's been close to
retirement age for some time
and I think that in general
you need to actually reduce the number
of political appointees there's like
four to five thousand uh that we have to
appoint with every change of
administration and it excessively
politicizes the Civil Service it means
that a lot of people a lot of positions
remain vacant you know sometimes for
years at a time and I think we also need
to change the incentives I mean both
positive and negative
uh you have to be able to
reward people that you know are
good performers or have spill skills
that are very specialized in Canada part
in the finance ministry there they have
an office that oversees public-private
Partnerships which are very complicated
approaches to infrastructure and a guy
that runs that office you know was
recruited off of Wall Street and he's
paid a million dollars uh Canadian uh
which in American dollars is still a lot
of money but you know they say well you
know that's how you have to pay somebody
with that kind of skill whereas we've
got a classification system that's 70
years old
it's such a disaster yeah it's designed
for a a government of Clerks and typists
you know yeah it's it's slow cumbersome
makes it very very difficult to recruit
people who have uh frankly the ability
to command High salaries in the private
sector where anyone who goes into it
then has to do it for such like this uh
sense of altruism and purpose yeah
um but even then uh the speed is so slow
that even if they want to do it they're
like I can't wait six 12 months for a
decision on uh no that's right you know
whether the compliance requirements for
getting a job in in the federal
bureaucracy are just ridiculous I
recently I I now once again have a
security clearance because I'm a trustee
of the Rand corporation that does
classified research and uh you know even
there they want to know every foreign
National I've met in the last seven
years now I'm uh you know you've been
around man you've probably met a lot of
foreign Nationals
hundreds and hundreds of people you know
and you know I can't possibly remember
all the all the people I've met over
that period so anyhow there's lots of
things like that that really stand in
the way and I see this in my students
you know hardly any of them you mean
your Stanford students are not all
clamoring to go work for the government
no no
I mean the ones that are actually more
public spirited you know they want to go
to work for an NGO or International
Organization but they don't want to go
into the federal government and you know
I mean I shouldn't laugh like we wish
they would but the fact is that they did
go right now uh you know like some of
them might cycle out after a certain
period because that they're not really
doing the kind of work they want or not
having the kind of impact they want I
mean that that's a problem too yeah
they're not being rewarded really for
good performance and so especially if
they're watching their classmates like
advance and make money and do all the
stuff they're like ah you know because
the the government's not in the habit of
rewarding uh Superstars or exceptional
performers yeah I mean there's some
effort to do that the partnership for
public service which is really the
premier organization that kind of looks
out for public servants has this annual
award called the I think it's the Samuel
J Hyman Awards or the Sammy's in which
they you know they they look for
exceptional uh civil servants uh public
servants and give them a you know at
least some recognition not a lot of
money but recognition and the stories
are just incredible Michael Lewis
actually wrote uh he's written a couple
of books about this but he wrote this
book The Fifth
about
some of the extraordinary people that
actually worked for the federal
government and nobody knows about these
people you know I mean yeah it's very
thankful as someone Anonymous Etc I mean
if there's something we could do to help
Elevate their profile uh it'd be it'd be
awesome so you close your book with an
appeal for moderation which I thought
was uh very very appropriate you talked
about how it was one of the original
virtues uh and
um I I would say too that
um you know that that call
um is also very very aligned with some
of the work we're doing and I'm going to
suggest to you Frank that there is I
don't know have you seen the comedian
Ronnie Chang
uh no
um well you should check him out but he
had a joke that uh people quoted to me
sometimes when I was running for
president but he said that uh that
America needs Asians to be the referee
uh because we we uh and his joke was we
don't have any skin in the game because
we can't make your sports teams
that we're here to
the the race War what was his argument
um but there is there was you know as
usual in humor like that there was some
you know truth to it in the sense that
Asian Americans tend to be a little bit
less ideological a little bit more
pragmatic and practical and uh and
interested in what's working uh and
what's not working and right now the two
parties are having increasingly
ideological conversations that don't
seem to be focused on uh you know people
just trying to live better lives
um so the fact that you appealed for
moderation at the end of your your book
I thought uh was was very uh powerful
and appropriate yeah well I think a lot
of our problems have to do with the fact
that uh
you know uh if we say that something's
good then 10 times as much is going to
be 10 times as good so markets are
basically a good way you know to
allocate scarce resources but that
doesn't mean that you know if you
marketize everything that you're going
to have a even better Society yeah
indeed the problem with uh you know with
the kind of neoliberal policies that we
pursued you know in the 80s and 90s same
thing with autonomy autonomy is basic to
liberalism we all want to be able to
make choices but that doesn't mean that
we should make choices about everything
uh you know that we get to make up our
own morality and you know we get to
decide on our own what's good and bad
because it's really that common shared
value that gives us a sense of community
and so in in all of those cases you know
being a little bit moderate uh in you
know uh something's a good thing but you
know maybe too much of it is a bad thing
maybe a little sense of moderation in
that respect would be helpful for all of
us
uh well that's a phenomenal note to
close on I will say when you talk about
our economic system I can't tell you how
many times I got annoyed when people
tried to set up this false capitalism
socialism uh dichotomy and you're like
look like you know what we need is uh
actually like intelligent regulatory
approaches that kind of curb the
excesses of unfettered uh capitalism uh
and most Americans could agree that you
know it's like there's going to be some
kind of intelligent Middle Ground uh but
folks had these like very very in my
mind just unproductive not very smart
like oh that's social that's capitalized
it's like you know come on like you know
like there's you know there's always
that there's always something practical
and pragmatic that you can find
um in in the middle generally speaking
about a lot of these topics
um and I I thought that you know your
book made a fantastic argument for that
in many different respects
um Frank thank you so much for joining
us liberalism and it's discontents by
Francis fukuyama one of his 10 books uh
so you know that this one is the one I
focused on because I thought it was well
one is the most recent and two I thought
it was the most up forwards alley
but you but you contributed a whole lot
uh to wisdom and political discourse uh
over the last not to date you my friend
but decades
so so congratulations for for that and
uh you know keep on making us smarter
and wiser and hopefully more liberal in
the classical sense
okay well thanks very much Andrew and
good luck to you and all your efforts
too today thanks yeah we're we're just
getting started really America more
liberal in a classical sense the most
people won't get what we're going for
there but some will okay very good
[Music]